joining us now to talk about how his
state is responding to all of this we
have the governor of Ohio
Mike DeWine governor thank you so much
for taking time out of your busy day to
talk to us governor you were from the
very beginning you have been one of the
most aggressive governors in terms of
the actions that you have taken to fight
the corona virus you shut down major
events before you had a single case in
the state you barred spectators from
major sporting events before the
league's canceled their seasons you were
the first to declare a statewide school
shut down and you even shut down the
polls you postponed a primary was it
worth it are those actions working well
I think they're working but we have to
keep going back you know it's like we're
I don't know what quarter of the
football game we're in but you got to
keep playing and so what I'm asking
although hyoeun's to do who are watching
today and when I ask them every day is
stay home I'll continue to have that
distance continue to use use the
judgment I want to really thank our
mayor's around Ohio they're doing a
phenomenal job I talked to the big-city
mayor's every every morning 11:30
they're really doing a good job in
making sure the message is out to all
their citizens as well so it's a team
effort and I think Ohioans are doing
well but we're we've got a long way to
go all of those actions having a
tremendous economic toll in your state
just like they are across the country
last week more than 270 two thousand
people in Ohio filed for unemployment
nearly half a million over the last two
weeks and Ohio recently had the second
largest increase nationwide in jobless
claims only Pennsylvania had more so
what is your message to people in Ohio
about how they are going to get through
this financially oh but the federal
government has done what our
congressional delegation has done our
Senators and Representatives and the
president is certainly going to help our
emphasis has been on let's get through
this let's get as many people through it
as we can let's stay alive because the
evidence shows
that when you look back at past
pandemics communities that did the
distancing did the things that they need
to do not only did they save more lives
but they were healthier and they were
coming out and they're healthier from an
economic point of view recent study that
was done by some economists I saw show
that so you know it's not either/or it's
not you one choice or the other we can
do both we can save lives let's get
through this and then let's move on one
things I've done is put together a group
of 20 business men and women to advise
us that's going to be helpful as we move
forward moving our economy for governor
nine states still have not issued formal
statewide stay at home orders is it time
for a nationwide stay at home order to
go into place well yeah I don't know the
situation all those states I don't know
where they are but I think would be
helpful if every governor did this I
think it's something that should be done
the vast majority I think over 90% of
the population of this country is now
under a stay at home order every state
surrounding us it has done it and did it
very aggressively do you think President
Trump should perhaps call these
governors and say hey it's time to do
this something they're all Republican
governors you're a Republican governor
is could you do something well I think
the governor I think the president has
signaled very strongly what he thinks
should happen you know I'm watching the
same news that you're watching and let
me just say this and White House has
been very responsive to us last Sunday I
called the White House I called the
president he was able to intervene with
the FDA get them moving faster on
something it was very very important to
us as we fought back against the corona
virus so they've been very aggressive
and every time we've reached out to them
they've been there
final question governor I only have a
few seconds left
president Trump has said that he's not
going to wear a mask you said that you
do intend to wear a face mask do you
think President Trump should maybe
rethink that and when he steps outside
wear a mask set a good example for all
Americans no you know a president does
what he needs to do or what I said was I
didn't work my fresh calm either when I
said it when I was in public then you
know I would do that my press conference
is a small number of people the
president's is a small number of people
kind of hard to talk directly through
the mask but you know well I say this
when I go out in public and I'll be out
I'll be doing some things this week even
a good social distance well I think it
does send a right signal to wear the
mask I think what it says is look we I
care about other people because the
masks were wearing don't really protect
us they protect other people governor
thank you so much best of luck in the
coming days and weeks